trouve notre envoyé spécial Mélina Huet
à Mikola Yves cette prise de soleda par
les Russes est-ce une victoire
symbolique
bien écoutez Judith vous l'avez dit à
Kiev dément est également les groupes
des forces armées de Leicester
ukrainienne démente également à leur où
je vous parle et on comprend bien la
difficulté à admettre la perte d'une
ville comme Solidar certes petite mais
vous l'avez dit très symbolique avait
avec barmouth de fait c'est une ville
avec celle de barmouth qui est sous le
feu depuis la fin mai et les autorités
ukrainiennes et les forces armées
ukrainiennes ont décidé dès le début de
cette offensive russe et bien de ne pas
lâcher un seul centimètre carré de
territoire aux forces aux forces armées
russes alors on a tendance à dire que
c'est l'Ukraine contre la Russie mais en
fait il y a trois parties prenantes il y
a évidemment les forces armées
ukrainiennes mais il y a également au
sein même de des forces armées russes
les forces disons traditionnelles et
puis il y a cette force privée cette
milice privée Wagner qui est sur le
terrain et c'est symbolique pour le
fondateur de cette milice privée Wagner
Prigogine qui serait lui-même sur le
terrain à l'heure où on parle et qui
combattrait lui-même au côté de sésame
alors pourquoi c'est symbolique parce
que et bien ce serait la plus grosse et
en tout cas la première victoire depuis
des mois pour les Russes et c'est pour
ça que Wagner depuis plusieurs jours
revendique avoir pris la totalité de la
ville de soléda alors que l'armée russe
a subi d'important revers que ce soit
dans le blast de harkif ou bien
récemment plus récemment à Helson qui a
été libéré le 11 novembre dernier alors
jusqu'ici et c'est là la grande
différence jusqu'ici les forces armées
russes démentaient que Wagner avait pris
la totalité de la ville de soleda et
aujourd'hui il l'affirme ça y est la
ville est tombée alors c'est bien
difficile de savoir si la totalité de la
ville est au mainterrus mais ce n'est
pas seulement une prise symbolique si
jamais elle était actée c'est aussi une
prise stratégique pourquoi parce que du
côté de Wagner de cette mélisse et bien
il y a là-bas à soledar qui signifie
donner le sel en ukrainien et en russe
il y a la plus grande mine de sel
d'Europe donc il y a un premier point
stratégique et financier pour Wagner qui
est habitué à saisir des endroits et
apprendre minétairement des endroits
notamment en Afrique qui sont à Fort de
ressources naturel mais ou que du côté
russe il y a également cette visée
stratégique qui est de récupérer à terme
d'aller jusqu'à cramator ce que jusqu'à
sloviance qui permettrait pour l'armée
russe non seulement cette victoire
symbolique on l'a dit mais également une
prise stratégique qui pourrait permettre
pour eux en tout cas de prendre en
tenaille l'armée ukrainienne